[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about class 1a student
Minoru Moneta one of the most divisive
characters in the boku no hero fandom
some love him and think he's hilarious
others hate him for being a perv and
most people have no idea how minute a
managed to get into class 1a in the
first place in this video we will be
talking about me Nita as a character and
about the true power of his quirk popoff
an ability that lets him pull extremely
sticky balls from his head and throw
them at his opponent the other day I
asked you guys what exactly you wanted
me to talk about as far as Moneta is
concerned and I got a lot of great
responses so I will be addressing those
in the video for next time I want to ask
you guys to come up with some crazy
theories about boku no hero and shared
them with me on Twitter and Instagram
just follow us at anime up roar and
reply to the pinned thread they can be
serious theories like who is the you a
traitor or joke theories like dec whose
father is actually spike from Cowboy
Bebop the only rule is that your
theories can't just be manga spoilers
they have to be theories but otherwise
anything goes knock yourselves out and
by the way if you enjoyed the boku no
hero content on this channel don't
forget to leave a like to let me know
and if you're new don't forget to
subscribe and Detroit smash that
notification bell Minoru Minetta is one
of the more interesting characters in
boku no hero to say the least he is a
short boy prone to freak outs and he is
known to be the class pervert who
constantly thinks about girls and even
tries to peek in on the girls in his
class when they are changing or in a
public bath because of this the girls
think he's a weirdo and mean it too
often ends up getting his little purple
ass kicked by the girls whenever he goes
too far Moneta has also set some
controversial things in the manga which
I won't get into because of spoilers but
needless to say the purpose of this
video is not to defend or justify
everything that mimetic does but rather
to talk about him as a character and his
work and also to talk about why the
creator of boku no hero
Kohei horikoshi decided to include a
character like Minetta in the first
place as previously mentioned me notice
quirk produces sticky balls on his head
that he can rip off and throw at
opponents while the balls stick to other
people and to objects and surfaces they
do not stick to Minetta and instead they
bounce off of him the stickiness of
metas balls actually varies if he is in
perfect health his balls will be sticky
for the whole day but if he is not
feeling well the stickiness of his balls
will suffer on top of that if Mineta
pops off too many balls in a short
period of time he begins to bleed so he
has to use his quirk in moderation
minetti's quirk has one named technique
which is known as great brush this
attack involves Mineta running towards
his opponent and throwing as many sticky
balls at them as possible the goal is to
overwhelm the opponent with an avalanche
of sticky balls and rendered the
opponent in mobile because the balls
keep them pinned to the ground and other
surfaces preventing them from moving on
top of using them as a weapon Minetta
can also use his balls of the ones
produced by his quirk for climbing and
moving around rapidly by bouncing off of
them despite often being portrayed as a
neurotic pervert there is more to me not
as a character than that he is also
shown to be very intelligent and even
though he often uses that intelligence
for perverted schemes during the final
exams our Mineta impresses everyone when
he uses serous tape to cover his mouth
and nose negating the effect of
midnight's quirk and then manages to
immobilize midnite using grape rush in
an area far enough from the gate for her
quirk to be ineffective not only that
but mimetic goes out of his way to grab
cero and help him through the gate which
demonstrates the Minetta can be a
committed and loyal classmate over on
twitter lord Minetta clearly a big fan
of Minetta wants me to talk about the
extremely divided fanbase as everyone
seems to either love Minotaur or hate
him now this is how I see things and why
I believe that horikoshi decided to
include him in class 1-a Mineta is first
and foremost a comic relief care
his pervy and somewhat neurotic nature
leads to a lot of humorous situations
and so it provides comic relief even in
otherwise tense situations such as the
attack of the villains at the usj we all
know that one kid in high school who was
always making sexual jokes and thinking
about sex way too much and if you didn't
know someone like that chances are that
you were that person in that sense
Moneta is based on real high school boys
who can get pretty pervy at that age the
difference is that Minetta takes it too
far he tries to manipulate the girls
into giving him fanservice and he even
tries to peek in on the girls when they
are changing or taking a bath obviously
this is unacceptable in the real world
and no one should try to peek or spy on
anyone else against their will whether
you're a guy or a girl
it doesn't matter do not do it and with
that said I don't think horikoshi is
actually promoting this type of behavior
you will notice that every time Moneta
tries to do something overly pervy he
ends up suffering severe consequences
like when he gets stabbed in the eye by
Jiro for trying to peek in on the girls
changing or when he gets pushed off the
wall by coda when he tries to peek in on
the girls in the bath the lesson that
horikoshi is trying to teach us isn't
that minute as behavior is acceptable
but rather that this type of behavior is
not OK and that it will have
consequences especially when the girls
you're trying to spy on have badass
quirks that they can use to teach you a
lesson
so horikoshi is using Minetta for comic
relief and also to teach us that going
too far and being a perv has
consequences but with that said Minetta
is more than just a one-dimensional
pervert character the fact that he shows
great intelligence and loyalty to his
classmates like Sarah demonstrates that
there is another side to him and that he
does have the potential to develop into
a good hero if he can learn to control
himself and if he can focus on improving
his abilities instead of only thinking
about girls also let's remember that
female characters like midnight and
pixie Bob can also be pervy and pixie
bob was flirty with some of the class 1
a male students even though she is 31
year
of age saying she wants to see them in
three years when they're 18 so there
might also be a bit of a double standard
here Lord Anna is wondering how in the
world that mean Etta passed the entrance
exam and end up in class 1a and someone
like Shinzo who has a powerful mind
control quirk ended up in 1c also known
as the general studies class and a few
other people on Twitter and Instagram
were also wondering about this exact
thing well we know that Moneta is
intelligent so the written portion of
the entrance exam wouldn't have been a
problem for him but the question is how
did Mina to pass the physical portion of
the exam first we have to remember that
mean Etta can use his sticky balls to
climb various surfaces including
buildings and the physical test was
conducted in an urban setting mean Etta
can also jump on his own balls and
bounce off of them allowing him to evade
the villain bots that would have been
attacking him at the exam mean Etta
might have been using these two
abilities climbing and bouncing to
somehow rescue other students and we
have to remember that points were also
granted for rescuing others in fact dec
who gained zero points for fighting
villains and he passed solely due to the
fact that he had high rescue points
alternatively Minetta might have used
his sticky balls to immobilize a bunch
of the villain BOTS like he did to
midnight with grey brush and that's how
he earned enough points to pass he took
out enough villains to get the points on
the other hand Shin souls mind-control
quirk only works on living creatures not
on robots so he would have been at a
disadvantage at the entrance exam since
his quirk would have been useless
knocks tock who says that minute eyes
the perfect disguise for all for one and
Joshua wants me to talk about why
Minetta is the you a traitor while I
agreed a minute of being a traitor or a
villain would be pretty funny I think
that if he was secretly evil he would
try harder to be inconspicuous a good
spy isn't going to constantly draw
attention to himself by acting like the
class pervert at least one would think
but you never know with Minetta he could
still turn out to be an evil genius I
mean just look at that ominous facial
expression double X double says that
minute
secret backstory is that his dad is
actually the grape guy from fruit of the
Loom that is pretty funny actually and I
have no idea why horikoshi decided to
design Minotaur with a grape inspired
quark and costume but you have to admit
that this makes a memorable I for one
would love to see more grape based
superhero representation in the Marvel
movies this institutionalised grapes ISM
has got to stop ninja asks why does mean
it'll look like someone stuffed a bunch
of grapes into the bottom half of an egg
you know what I'm not even going to
respond to this how dare you body shame
Minetta he is stunning and brave my
buddy caster for life wants to see a
video on why Mineta is an evil
Australian spy think you got the wrong
anime caster you're thinking of rebel
from Code Geass over on the anime upper
Instagram we also had a bunch of
comments about minute up being the you a
traitor why he is such a perv and how he
passed the entrance exam in the first
place young to see wants me to talk
about what Mineta means to the anime
industry as the first mainstream anime
character who proudly embraces the
stickiness of his balls I think that
Mineta is a true pioneer for the sticky
balls community the anime dude says that
without Mineta there never would have
been a cheerleaders scene in season 2
also he is one of the authors favorite
characters so the anime dude can
actually imagine him playing a
relatively big role in future arcs in
all seriousness I do think that
horikoshi plans to develop Mineta as a
character we've already seen glimpses of
his intelligence and willingness to help
out his classmates so I do think that
Moneta has the potential to grow out of
his parfaits and become a more balanced
character and a true hero in the future
and that is it for this video on Minoru
Minetta I hope you enjoyed it and if you
did don't forget to leave a like to let
me know if you have it to be new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
Detroit smash that notification bell so
you can be notified whenever another
boku no hero video is up and don't
forget to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar if you want to
participate in the next video remember
the next video topic is crazy theories
about boku no hero
now before you go be sure to leave a
comment down below I want to know your
thoughts about Moneta do you like him
do you hate him do you just not care let
me know as always thank you all so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]